osorno 1 octubre 1983 escuela españa de
n 363 la profesora va directamente a la
sala de clases entra como
distinto lleva un bolso en la mano o una
carpeta y da las primeras instrucciones
a sus estudiantes los estudiantes la
miran incrédulos la gran mayoría no se
daba cuenta de esta nueva energía que
traía la profesora resulta que un
porcentaje menor de estudiantes y le
pareció extraño la profesora después de
dar un par de instrucciones se dirige
hasta el pizarrón toma la tiza y
comienza a escribir pasaron dos minutos
termina de escribir toda la pizarra y
entrega una nueva instrucción al momento
de entregar la instrucción
simultáneamente entrega una hoja para
cada estudiante
los más incrédulos que no se daban
cuenta de lo que estaba ocurriendo
siguen observando y aprovechan cada
minuto para hacer desorden y reírse pero
había un porcentaje menor de estudiantes
que estaban muy conectados con lo que
estaba ocurriendo y se dan cuenta que lo
que aparece en la hoja era exactamente
lo mismo que estaba en la pizarra
pasaron un par de segundos y esta
profesora va directamente un bolso saca
una radio cassette
con lo que el casete y empieza a sonar
una canción
si se la saben me ayudas
en la remota prehistoria junto al mamut
del milodón vivía un chico rudo y feo
que usaba elipses de visión tenía su
departamento en una cueva en la región
cazaba [ __ ] para el sustento era el
hombre de cromagnon
el hombre de cro el hombre de más el
hombre de un hombre de cromagnon hombre
tan fuerte y peludo y tan vacanudo como
existió pom pom pom pom pom y se repite
15 veces por razones de tiempo ya
estamos grabando así que no podemos
echar piedras
han pasado cerca de 35 años y un grupo
importante de estudiantes ese hecho pasó
desapercibido 35 años después uno de
esos estudiantes tiene dos hijas una de
siete y otra de dos no me van a creer
pero la canción de cuna de mis dos hijas
es el hombre de cromagnon todos los días
de su vida se han quedado dormidas
escuchando el hombre de cromagnon
la más pequeña cuando ya en el coche no
quiere dormir sacar la cabeza y me dice
pom pom pom pom en los viajes familiares
pom pom pom pom
ahí descubrí la importancia del
aprendizaje significativo de ese
perdurable de ese duradero mi nombre es
carlos ulloa soy profesor de tomo y lomo
me encanta lo que hago dentro de las
cosas que hago
hay mucha disrupción hay mucha
creatividad hay mucha innovación pero
por sobre todo hay muchos
cuestionamientos en una de esas
asignaturas hablamos de un personaje que
cambió el paradigma las comunicaciones
ese que está ahí en mi espalda un
superstar en innovación en creatividad
en emprendimiento y por sobre todo
cambió el paradigma de las
comunicaciones cuando me invitaron hasta
acá dije me tengo que poner en el lugar
y hacer un acto de empatía con los
asistentes por eso hice esa previa y
cuando me puse en el lugar de este señor
me puse a pensar
y elementos pueden ser interesantes para
poder compartir a propósito qué estamos
hablando desde el vaso medio lleno y
estamos hablando en perspectiva
ese joven efectivamente era yo miren la
actitud
por favor
esta misma profesora que mira la verdad
no no me recuerdo el nombre nos planteó
en una clase
y esto no me hace nada no puede ser no
puede ser nos planteó
nacieron dibujos perspectivas 3º básico
cuarto básico para nosotros era chino
y no comparto un dibujo muy parecido al
de la imagen
yo recuerdo muy bien el momento en que
esos árboles salían y aparecían en los
postes de luz unos los primeros más
grandes y los que seguían más pequeños
mi papá
tiene recuerdos importantes de mi
infancia y cuando le comenté a lo que
venía
le dije papá tenéis que buscar si hay
algún dibujo porque lo guardaba para
proceder de arte están bien y no me van
a creer en exclusiva les voy a mostrar
el dibujo
que quise hacer unos años atrás en esos
tiempos cuando
logré hacer ese dibujo
eran otros tiempos ahí está mi curso ahí
está mi escuela ahí está mi director ahí
está mi profesor jefe y están todos mis
compañeros estas fotos me emociona
porque un recuerdo importante de mi vida
y sobre todo me evoca esta profesora que
generó algo en nuestros compañeros y
fundamentalmente pero también es triste
porque el que está ahí soy yo mire
encerraban el círculo
eran otros tiempos los que estuvieron en
estos tiempos ya sabrán la preocupación
era otra que los estudiantes no
aceptaran del sistema que aprendieran
las operaciones básicas que aprendieran
a leer y escribir liderazgo creatividad
innovación trabajo colaborativo eran
cosas utópicas los tiempos cambiaron en
esa misma calle que les mostré al
comienzo al final hay una universidad
donde yo actualmente trabajo
año 96 yo veía que mis compañeros
pasaban con esta actitud a dónde vas a
la biblioteca que llevas en esa carpeta
papers
y donde los guardas porque no veo qué
llevas tantas hojas en un disquete
3 megas de capacidad para la época era
una revolución
yo estaba el margen yo me había quedado
en la tarea 800 x el modo usuario para
jugar un par de juegos pero eso ya era
como
una cosa nueva
esto me preocupó y me llevó a pensar
cómo podemos enfrentar este nuevo
escenario los tiempos cambiaron y parece
ser que todos se están sumando y yo me
estoy quedando atrás
y ahí aparece
otro desafío
un zafiro que aparece en perspectiva que
ya le van a encontrar algún tipo de
sanción
en la universidad prestaba en este
computador cada 15 minutos el señor
portal que estaba a cargo de la
biblioteca que recibía tu carnet que
estaba escrito a mano
y te decía tienes 15 minutos para
ocuparlo y yo me animé tomé mi carpeta
compre un par de busquets sin saber
usarlo y voy hasta la biblioteca con la
misma actitud con que iban mis
compañeros pero sin la debida
preparación ese fue un gran error que
hoy día lo puedo comprender muy bien
entro a la biblioteca entro a esta sala
afortunadamente era una sala que estaba
cubierta y el primer desafío fue
encender el computador use la lógica de
la tarde 800 xl y los primeros minutos
miraba el computador y trataba de
encenderlo el tiempo empezó a correr y
yo me empecé a esperar la verdad es que
ya empecé en la etapa 2 que era empezar
a rodear el computador mirándolo
buscando algún tipo de agujero de algún
dispositivo donde yo pudiese encenderlo
la historia es triste no lo que
encontrar terminaron los 15 minutos y
debía abandonar la sala cuando el señor
pozal me pregunta a carlos cómo te fue
excelente baje mucha información mira
como mira como voy con estas con esta
información es un momento complejo de
mucha frustración y yo creo que
representa escenarios cambiantes
donde si tú no estás preparado o no
tienes la disposición para prepararte
pueden aparecer hechos muy parecidos es
los tiempos cambian pasaron 20 años no
me van a creer pero en el computador de
la primera imagen había un código de
inventario fui donde el encargado de
inventario de la universidad donde yo
trabajo y el tipo es tan ordenado que me
dijo si existen posibilidades de que el
computador esté tengo imágenes
exclusivas del encuentro
me encontré con este computador el
encuentro fue bastante positivo nos
reconciliamos
desde ese momento estoy pasando la vida
con mi teléfono celular con la carcasa
que me diseño mi hija de 7 años
y las cosas empiezan a aparecer en
perspectiva
en un efecto
si hay un diseñador por favor después
puedo contarles cómo lo hice
en un efecto que puede generar caos
estragos
en la misma calle ramírez osorno 1983
aparece un joven que tenía muchas ganas
de hacer deporte yo era futbolero
futbolero futbolero
me regalaban zapatos de fútbol medias
canilleras short polera del mejor equipo
de chile no entrar en detalles porque la
gente pues no va a entender y todos los
días que iba entrenamiento miraba mis
zapatos me los colocaba los observados
los dejaba un poquito allá los volvió a
observar me los volvía a colocar hasta
que me quedaba dormido hasta que un
entrenador que no era profesor
me dijo algo que me marcó creo que
positivamente
crecido 10 centímetros por sobre la
media creo que hasta 15 la estatura que
tengo hoy día la tenía cuando estaba en
séptimo básico carlos creo que tuve en
el fútbol no vas a rendir eres un tanto
torpe con tus movimientos dado que estás
en pleno crecimiento
te sugiero que te cambies de deporte y
puedas probar con el básquet
hoy día 25 años después puedo darme
cuenta la importancia que tiene lo que
nosotros decimos y dejamos de decir
independiente si trabajas en una escuela
no liceo en un hospital en una clínica a
veces lo que dices o dejas de decir
puede generar un efecto en este caso el
efecto fue bastante positivo porque me
dediqué al basketball gracias al
basketball conocí a muchas personas
logré jugar muchos campeonatos recorrer
el país y algunos y otros países logré
estudiar dos carreras gracias al
basketball conocer mucha gente y
eventualmente un par de años jugar de
manera profesional lo cual claramente
fue bastante positivo en esta mirada en
perspectiva
desde ese punto de vista
aparece un elemento que
y yo siento que es muy importante
y justamente es eso que tiene que ver
con estos hitos que se ven en
perspectiva reconocen la carátula sí
perfecto muy bien año 97 4 mil 990 en
las disquerías 4 mil 990 junte la plata
abrí mi persona al exterior me dirigí a
esta misma calle
en la anterior
en la anterior que falta de nuevo voy
señorita necesito el cassette de tiro de
gracias porque el disco era poco
amigable porque muy pocos tenían esta
posibilidad dale más fuerte por favor
cuando el juego se hace verdadero cuando
el juego se hace verdadero el juego el
juego cuando el juego se hace verdadero
bienvenido al laberinto eterno de fuego
trato de seguir cantando pero va a
seguir la música sigue la música hoy 25
años después 20 años después esto fue el
año 96
yo soy profe trabajo con jóvenes
en ese momento cuando puse el casete
ocurrieron cosas en mi cabeza pensar que
un grupo de jóvenes de un sector
periférico de santiago eran capaces de
crear esto de incluir un clavo de 4
pulgadas en la carátula
me invitó a darme cuenta 20 años después
del talento que día a día yo veo en las
salas de clases jóvenes que muchas veces
no tienen la oportunidad de desplegar
todo ese talento yo me lo cuestiono
cuando veo esta imagen
darle la siguiente
aparece
esta foto mire en el clavo de 4 pulgadas
que está dentro incorporado dentro de
éste
las cosas siguen viéndose en perspectiva
a veces no te das cuenta lo que ocurrió
mucho tiempo atrás y hoy día le da
sentido si yo tuviese una bolita mágica
podría interpretar muchas de esas cosas
que ocurrieron en ese momento o vivían
leyendo algunos libros que tienen que
ver con esto el encuentro sustento y
sentido a todo lo que estoy hablando
cuando el juego se hace verdadero el
aprendizaje se hace significativo cuando
tú tomas decisiones y te adaptas a los
distintos escenarios y eres capaz de ver
en perspectiva
partes de una manera pero terminas de
otras en un momento en las mañanas yo
era profe en las tardes o a mediodía era
quienes yo lo vi en las noches
eventualmente salida correcta mejorar mi
estado o mi condición física hasta que
llega el momento en que todas estas
cosas se alinean se ponen en perspectiva
le das una interpretación y
efectivamente el juego se hace verdadero
muchas gracias